she writes yes I love being in dangerous
situations with dudes in the habit of
monetizing women for cash
by pimping them out and who've been
thrown off reality TV shows for hitting
their girlfriends I think that would go
well for me because I'm a lobotomy
patient with the humiliation feta she
thought she'd be real clever there I was
like
so again
this irritated me maybe this this
irritated me actually more than any of
the comments do you know why because
again I can't stand the infantilization
of women I cannot stand it so I will
give you my reply and then I'm going to
expand on that a second I wrote If adult
women choose to participate in a
consensual webcam business I want to
vandalize them by claiming they've been
pimped out he was thrown off a reality
show because of King video the girl in
the video defended him not my thing in
either case
okay
again I don't like Kink I'm not into it
like I don't need my sex to be filled
with injury I'm just not my style not my
thing
um I personally don't like webcam like I
don't I don't it doesn't appeal to me
it's not something that I've thought to
do it's it's not my thing right
but are we talking about grown adult
women or not because he did the King
video and the girl in the video who had
been his girlfriend came out and said
that's what we used to do I didn't have
a problem with it it was like we were
putting it on for the camera a little
bit and there's nothing going on there
there's no story there
so that's it that's it what am I
supposed to say oh no honey no no no let
me infantilize her no no that's not good
for you didn't your mommy ever tell you
no I'm not interested in playing that
role I'm interested in letting adults be
adults make the choices they make for
themselves and be honest with themselves
but what they like what they don't like
it's not my life to live I'm not here to
boss everybody around and pull Doritos
out of their mouth and tell them not to
do king videos you're an adult you do
what you want same for webcam business
he said in the video at one point
somewhere he said I reached out to my he
was looking to make money and he reached
out to I guess it was ex-girlfriends or
maybe it was girlfriends like he said
had a few girlfriends going on at the
time and he reaches out to them he says
this is what we're gonna do and he even
says at one point one or two of them I
think laugh decided it wasn't for them
they weren't held there against their
will
the girls were entering into a Business
Partnership they decided they wanted to
make money that way they were adults
it's up to them
did he chain them to the bed that would
be a different story I don't have
evidence of that
were they held against their will I also
don't have evidence of that
am I again going to infantilize these
women and say no no no should we be
doing this to all women that do only
fans should I be going up to every woman
on only fans no no no you can't do
that's bad you're you're a little baby
and you need to be told that that's not
good I have no interest in that you want
you're an adult woman you want to do
only fans go do it I don't care
I don't care it's not my life to live do
I think it's the can I weigh in on the
pros and cons and give my opinion sure
but I'm going to tell you what to do
same thing for people who get involved
in pornography adults I have no problem
with that I'm not going to do it doesn't
interest me I'm not going to watch it I
think it's bad for Society at large I'm
going to weigh in on why I think it's
bad for Society at large I'm going to
tell you what to do you're a grown-ass
woman so what I love about this is the
infantilization again the left will
particularly women on the left will
constantly tell you that they're
cheering for women we love women we're
champions for women and at every turn
they they get an opportunity they will
remind you that they feel women are
incapable of making their own decisions
and that women shouldn't be held to a
standard of personal responsibility and
that women just they they can't think or
take care of themselves in any capacity
they're being pimped out
how do you know they're being pimped out
how do you know that you assumed why
because you infantilized them that's why
if you want to watch the full episode
click right here and if you want to ask
me a question talk one-on-one send me a
FaceTime video join a video with a group
of your friends and me you gotta
download manect and you gotta join me
there it's gonna be really hot
[Music]